foreign
[Music]
with each film Ghostface is getting more
intense you should followed me here and
it's Gonna Keep Coming For Us
this ghost face is the most ruthless and
just killing people for killing sake
the rules have changed We are continuing
to top what came before there's never
been one like me I'm something different
setting it in New York adds so much
harder guys Ghostface can hide amongst
so many people
this movie pushes things farther than
they've ever been we need to fight back
there's a relentlessness that is unique
to this specific ghost face
okay
you got a problem here guy
[Music]
thank you
I had this Secret
there's a Darkness inside of me
it followed me here
and it's Gonna Keep Coming For Us
we share a certain history
this isn't like any other ghost face
what is this place a shrine
we've got a lure him in
we execute them
hello let's play a game you know you're
like the 10th guy to try this right it
never works out for the [__] in The
Mask
Maybe
but there's never been one like me Gail
I'm something
different
that's why I'm gonna shoot you in the
[__] head
thank you
you want me so let's finish this
guys
[Music]
foreign